so when you see a sectograph right
we're talking about a circular pie chart
type thing like this okay
now i will point out you don't actually
have to draw a pie chart to do this
question
but it's so much easier to visualize
what's going on if you have just like a
simple
draw a simple circle for yourself now
remember if you draw in like say let's
start our
pie chart at 12 o'clock at noon okay
that's where i tend to start mine
because it's a convenience store
if you start from there yeah then going
all the way around
the circle how many degrees is that
that's 360 right so i need to know that
number
because my pie chart my whole sector
graph should represent
all of the different things all added up
together so that i've got everyone all
in one graph
so good morning 360 degrees therefore
needs to represent whatever the sum of
each of these ears
okay so okay frequency he added up with
me and 3 and 6 is
9 plus 12 is 21
26 and then 30. okay
so therefore um this should be
all the way around those 360 degrees i'm
never going to write this
360 degrees
should represent 30 what are these
things
um these are people right these are
people and they are traveling in a
particular way
okay so 360 degrees it represents
30 people
okay great now um from that i could
construct this entire graph by saying
well if i don't have 30 people if i only
have say
three people that's all for walkers then
what angle would
match up to that what would i have to
divide this right hand side by
to get to three people i'd divide by
10 right so if i divided this by 10
i'd divide this by 10. so three people
would become good morning
36 degrees so that makes sense you get
your two cracked out you draw it
okay but that was just a way to
illustrate what's the approach how do i
think about answering this question
now look at what it's asking it says
uh what's the angle for the sector that
represents the
bus people okay so how many of them are
there
there are 12. so instead of going from
here probably what would be easiest for
me just think
okay um there's no neat number very like
nice whole number that i can divide this
by to get
12. okay so what i'll do is um go back
to thinking about ratios
i'm going to use what we call the
unitary method i'm going to get this in
terms of
one person is that a k
because then i can multiply it to
whatever i like so let's actually do
this working now because this will be
useful to us
360 divided by 30 years
that's 12 degrees right 12 degrees
for one person so having gone down to
one i'm using one so that i can get back
up to 12. so i'm going to multiply both
sides by 12.
um 12 times 12 is 144 degrees
is that one of the answers
cool actually okay uh there's one other
thing you could have done just because
like
if this was a um a free response
question short response
you have to work this out of course but
just looking at this question it happens
to be multiple choice
so i could have done something a little
bit cheap if you have a look at the
answers here
can you see we probably could have made
a good guess as to the fact that it's
this one
as opposed to the other ones how can we
guess
okay yeah look it's like this guy is
like more than double the size of the
nearest
um the nearest other kind of transport
right
so therefore it makes sense you're going
to get a huge angle for that so this at
least just confirmed that intuition
does that make sense okay wonderful i've
held your hand through number one do you
reckon you could have a go at number two
i'm just going to draw for you
if you can't remember what a divided bar
chart or a
divided bar graph what it looks like
it's exactly what it sounds like
you have a bar and then you divide it up
into
certain sizes
based on what they are proportionately
basically it's a bit like a sector graph
if you
sort of cut it apart and then roll it
all out okay or unroll it i should say
so think about that you're going to have
instead of like degrees around the
circle
you're going to have different lengths
that's what this question is asking
about
okay so good morning why don't you have
a shot at number two
eliana was sick of something
she wasn't giving him
okay so number two number two
have a think about it you can use a very
similar
approach you might like to draw yourself
a rough one so you know what's going on
think about what's all the way around
the question itself
tells you and then i'll apply a similar
approach and see what answer
you get out okay so i'll give you a
moment to gather yourself
and have a go at number two okay all
right let's have a shopping
you can tell me what sort of working
could i put down
to try and start to unpack this what
might you put on the diagram for
instance
okay awesome 200
millimeters equals a hundred percent now
this is great you can see by the way
this hundred percent
um she just picked it out perfectly
because she's read out from here like
what is this
what number is this about just like up
here we looked and we're like oh it's
people
okay who are traveling in different ways
here's about percentage of total sales
so perfect okay now we then look over
and we say
well which one of which one of these
are they looking for it's ladies where
right so they want 45
now again unlike every other number
there's no neat number whole number i
can divide this by
to get to 45. right so what might my
next step
step be what can i do what might i
divide
both sides by to get to something yeah i
think divided by 100 would be great
that's kind of like a go-to option
because if you're not sure just divide
by
however many number of units you have
because that'll get you to
one and from one you can get anywhere
you like so having divided by a hundred
that tells me
every one percent of sales represents
two millimeters on my graph
right one percent on the back of itself
so then all i need to do is get to 45 so
i'm going to multiply
both sides
what do you think makes sense
yeah cool yeah so as in now
presumably what i would do is i would go
ahead i would draw my thing out
i'd make sure that this is 20
centimeters long and then i'd mark out
my um
my nine centimetres and that would be my
you know ladies wear sales etc
okay